So anyway,
the course I'm going to teach is called financial theory.
And I'm going to talk about,
I'm going to teach an actual class.
I'm gonna spend the first half of the class talking about the course and why you
might be interested in it.
And then I'm going to start with the chorus.
I'm going to not that many lectures available in the semester,
so I'm not going to waste this one.
So the first half the class is going to be about why to study it and the
mechanics of the course and the second half of the lecture is going to be
actually the first part of the course.
They'll give you maybe an idea of whether you'll find the course interesting
too.
So,
um,
I think I'll turn this won't have too much power point here.
So you should know that finance was not taught until 10 years ago at Yale.
It was regarded by the deans and the classically minded faculty of the arts and
sciences as a vocational subject,
not worthy of being taught to Yale undergraduate.
Um,
it was growing more and more famous,
however,
in the world.
And there was a band of business school professors,
Fisher Black Robert Merton,
William Sharpe,
Steve Ross,
Myron shoals,
Merton Miller,
who had a huge following in business schools teaching the subject and who
students went off on to Wall Street and more or less dominated the investment
banking,
uh,
parts of Wall Street and became extremely successful.
Uh,
finance became the most highly paid profession.
It became those highly paid faculty in the university,
although they were all in business schools.
They're more physics PhDs working in finance now than there are working in
physics.
Um,
so this merry band of financial theory,
professors didn't really believe in regulation.
They believed markets left unfettered,
uh,
work best of all.
They believed in what they call the efficient markets.
And the idea that acid prices reflect all the available possible information.
So an implication of that is that if you want to find out whether a company's
doing well or not,
you don't have to take the trouble to read all their financial boards.
Just look at their stock price.
If you wanted to know whether a country is doing well or not,
you don't have to study its entire political system.
And,
uh,
you know,
current events,
just look at the general stock market of the country and that will tell you they
believe that you could make as good returns in the market as a lay person,
as you could as an expert because all the experts were competing to try and get
the best possible price.
And so the price itself reflected all their knowledge and wisdom and opinions.
And so the lay person could take advantage of that by buying stocks.
Everybody should be an investor.
They felt,
uh,
a monkey throwing darts at a dart board would do as well as any of the greatest
experts.
Now,
their own theory was
basically contradicted by their own experience because all of them seem to go
out into the world,
uh,
and,
and invest in almost all of the mating extraordinary returns and made a huge
amount of money,
all of which made them even less popular in the Faculty of Arts and Sciences.
So a critical part of their theory was that the markets are so efficient,
driven by people like them who are competing to exploit every advantage and
therefore compete away every advantage.
And by doing that,
uh,
put all the information they have into the prices.
The implication of that theory is that there's an extraordinarily clever way of
computing the value of most investment assets and about deciding when a
financial decision is a good thing to do or not.
And that was the heart of what they taught in these business schools,
these algorithms for valuing assets and making optimal financial decisions.
Uh,
one striking thing is that the people they studied the business school,
the,
uh,
the business people and the investment bankers,
they studied,
adopted their language.
So this had never happened in academia before.
I mean,
anthropologists study,
you know,
primitive tribes and different kinds of people all the time.
And not one of them I'd venture to say,
has ever taken over all the language invented by anthropologists to behave
themselves in their own societies.
But the business people that these professors were studying ended up using
exactly the language created,
uh,
in academia.
Now,
Yale was very different.
There was no divide between economist and a finance people.
All these other,
you know,
the business school finance people in,
at,
at Yale,
the greatest economist and yells history.
We're actually very interested in finance.
Maybe there were financial economist to begin with.
So the greatest Yale economist and the first half of the 20th century was Irving
Fisher.
You hear a lot about,
he wrote possibly the first economics phd at Yale.
There was no economist to teach him,
so he had to write his phd with Gibbs.
Uh,
the great,
maybe the greatest American physicist of the time.
There's a building as you know,
and science hill named after Gibbs.
And,
uh,
you'll,
you'll hear more about his dissertation and the 1890s,
but he was a mathematical economist and econometrician,
but he invented almost all of his economics in order to study finance.
The most famous yellow economist of the second half of the 20th century was
James Tobin,
a famous macro economist.
Uh,
the most famous macro economist,
possibly of the 22nd half of the 20th century after Keynes,
a great Keynesian,
but he got the Nobel prize for work he did on finance and economics.
Finance was incredibly interesting to him.
So Bob Shiller and I went to Yale and we basically said to the deans,
there's a long tradition of finance and economics hand in hand,
um,
at Yale.
And so it's not a vocational subject.
It's actually central to economics and central to understanding the economy in
central to understanding the global economy.
So we'd like to teach it to Yale undergraduates and we believe a few of them
will actually take the course.
And so they agreed to let us do it.
And so what we've been teaching it now for the,
for the last 10 years,
so as you know,
um,
Schiller is very,
has been very critical of the business,
uh,
efficient markets tradition.
Uh,
he feels that these finance professors left something essential out of the whole
story.
What they left out was psychology.
They left out the idea of fads and uh,
rumors,
a narratives which they thought,
which he thinks has as big an effect on prices as the hard information about
profits that the business school professors imagine drove profits.
Um,
I myself have been quite critical of the financial theory.
I started off as a straight,
pure mathematical economist.
Um,
it,
to me,
economics is almost a branch of logic and philosophy that happened to tell you
something about the world.
Um,
so I got my phd with Ken Arrow who you'll hear a lot about very shortly.
And I came to Yale.
Uh,
I'd been a Yale undergraduate.
I came back to Yale and I joined the Coles Foundation.
And the coulds foundation's motto was basically,
can we make economics more mathematical economics?
Social Science ought to be,
uh,
amenable to mathematical analysis just like physics or chemistry is.
And people didn't believe this at first.
And the coulds foundation,
uh,
which you'll hear a lot about in these lectures,
led the revolution in economics,
transforming it from a,
a,
a verbal subject,
political economy into a mathematical subject.
Well,
I decided around 1989 that since I did mathematical economics and there are all
these finance people doing all kinds of mathematical things on Wall Street,
uh,
and doing it very successfully,
you know,
I thought I might just check out what they were doing so it might be fun to see
what they were up to.
So I,
I went to,
uh,
to Wall Street and I joined.
Uh,
most people I knew,
fact professors I knew went to Goldman Sachs.
There was a famous,
uh,
finance professor who I mentioned before named Fisher Black,
who was there at the time and he attracted a lot of people.
And so that was the traditional thing to do.
But I decided to go to a little or firm called kidder Peabody.
And,
uh,
one thing,
it was the seventh biggest investment bank at the time and one thing led to
another.
Um,
and they decided that they wanted to reorganize their research department in
Fixed Income.
And since I was a professor there and I did mathematical economics and I'm just
there for the whole year.
Somebody said,
the director of Fixed Income Department said,
why don't you take charge of it and hire a new fixed income research department
for me.
So I did.
And ultimately there were 75 people in the department all the time.
I was a professor at Yale and after five years,
um,
kidder Peabody even though was 135 years old,
formed by a famous family.
The name should sound Peabody familiar to you?
Um,
it closed down after 135 years,
five years after I got there,
I had to invite the 75 people I'd hired into my office and say,
you're fired.
And then I went next door to the office next to mine and the guy there said,
And so that was my first taste of Wall Street.
And after that,
um,
six of us founded a hedge fund called Ellington,
capital management,
um,
which was a mortgage hedge fund.
And uh,
we had,
um,
I'll tell you a lot about,
uh,
about it.
It started after the kid are closing,
um,
uh,
as a rather small hedge fund.
But it grew into a very big mortgage hedge fun.
In fact,
the biggest mortgage hedge fund in the country,
although recently we found out that path practically everybody who trades
mortgages is basically a hedge fund.
Fannie Mae,
Freddie Mac,
they're all basically hedge funds.
So it doesn't mean anything anymore to say that you're a big mortgage hedge
fund.
But anyway,
we almost went out of business in [inaudible] 98 a subject,
a story I'll tell you at great length and then we just suffered through this
disastrous last year or two.
But we're still here.
So these experiences of course have colored my understanding of Wall Street and
my approach to the subject.
So I took on in my theoretical work,
finance and economic theory on its own terms.
I didn't think like Schiller to introduce psychology and economics.
I just take it on in its own terms,
on its own mathematical terms.
And what I found was that there are two things missing in the standard theory.
One is that it basic,
it implicitly assumes you can buy insurance for everything.
That's the assumption that's called complete markets.
And secondly,
it leaves out collateral entirely.
So you'll never see almost in any single economics textbook the idea of
collateral or leverage.
And those,
I think the idea that you can't get insurance for everything and that you need
collateral,
you know,
you have to be able to convince someone you're going to pay him back if you
borrow money and collaterals.
And most convincing way of persuading him he's going to be paid back the lender.
Those two things were missing from the standard theory.
So I've built a theory around incomplete markets and leverage,
um,
uh,
which,
which is a critique of the standard theory.
So in a way,
Schiller and I have been vindicated by the crash.
I mean,
uh,
so let me just show you a picture here.
Oh,
maybe I will.
Um,
you know how bad the crash was.
So let's look at the Dow Jones.
Dow Jones.
Uh,
the Dow Jones is an average of 30 stocks and what their value is.
We'll talk more about it later,
but here it is,
back to 1913 moving along breezily going up and up and um,
you know,
there were a few blips which we'll come to later like this one.
Okay,
in 1929 and then,
but look what happened lately.
Look at that.
The Dow Jones was up at 14,000 and it drop until,
you know,
6,500 something like that.
I'm more than a 50% drop and now it's gone 50% up again.
So if you believe these finance professors you'll have,
you'd have to say that everybody realized that future profits in America,
we're going to be less than half what they thought they were going to be before.
And that's why the stock market dropped.
And then miraculously when it hit a bottom,
everybody figured,
oh my gosh,
we misunderstood things.
Actually it's not nearly that bad.
And things are 50% higher because now that people think that profits really
weren't going to go,
you know,
didn't drop in half.
They only,
it didn't drop by 50%.
They only dropped by 25%.
And that would be the only way,
according to the old theory,
to explain what happened.
Now,
fifth Shiller would just say,
well,
everybody's,
you know,
they're crazy.
They got this into their head that the world is just going to be great.
And then,
you know,
some rumors started and things were so high and people,
the narrative change and they thought things were terrible.
And you know,
that's his story and I'm not sure how he gets it to go up again.
They changed their mind again,
but okay.
So,
um,
all right.
Now by the way,
it's a little bit better to look at the,
uh,
dow in,
in um,
sorry,
correcting for inflation and then you see that,
uh,
you know,
the 1929 crash looks and this is on a log scale.
So the same abs,
you know,
remember before the depression,
the stock market was so low,
it's grown so much over 100 years that it hardly seem like anything was
happening.
Well now in large scale,
uh,
you know,
going up two of these is multiplying by 10.
You see that the,
the in the Depression in 1929 through the early thirties,
the stock market fell.
You know,
I don't remember what it is and looks like it's almost two things is what I
think it's 80 or 90% and uh,
the,
the fall this time has been,
you know,
much smaller,
50%,
not 90%.
So it's a whole thing down but not to,
not to things down.
Okay.
So it's not a whole thing down.
It's less than that.
If you know a whole thing down we the square root of 10 or a three,
you know,
a third,
it didn't go down two thirds,
it went down less than two thirds and went down 50%.
So the actual percentage drop was much worse in the depression than it is now.
Okay.
But now we're going to come,
come back to all these things.
What else can we get out of these numbers?
I just want you to notice a couple other things.
Suppose you look,
so these numbers are all very interesting.
If your mathematical,
these are sort of the sorts of things you pay attention to.
So these efficient markets guys,
they looked at the change in price every month.
So there's a lot to say for their theory.
They said,
look,
it goes up and down randomly.
In fact,
we'll see that there are all kinds of tests about whether you can predict it's
going to go up tomorrow on the basis of how it would did yesterday.
And the answer is no.
It's very difficult to predict what the stock market's going up or down seems to
be random.
Well,
it's random and they used to think it was normally distributed.
A lot of people argue is normally distributed,
but you know it's hard.
You never get these gigantic outliers.
If things are normally distributed,
they're just way too unlikely to happen.
So Mandelbrot was,
who was a Yale professor who retired a couple of years ago,
all the way.
It wasn't when he formed,
his theory is the inventor of fractals.
He said this couldn't possibly be a random walk in the traditional Brownian
motion sense of the word,
because you'd never get these big outliers.
But he offered no explanation for why they might be there.
And you know,
I don't know,
Schiller has an explanation either.
I mean,
isn't that people suddenly get shocked one day and then the next week they
changed their mind and things aren't so bad after all.
Um,
but you'll see that the theory of collateral and margins does explain these
kinds of things.
Okay.
Now let's just look at the Dow.
Uh,
not that we just looked at the Dow.
Let's look at another,
the s and p 500.
Okay,
so,
Ooh,
um,
where's the s and p 500,
sorry.
Okay,
here we go.
Here's the s and p 500 data.
Okay,
so here's the history,
the s and p 500.
It looks very similar to the d to the dao,
and now,
except we have longer history back to 1871.
So I just want to point out one more thing.
In the s and p 500.
So this is an average of 500 stocks,
not just 30,
but it's more or less the same.
But let's look at the same thing.
Taking the log rhythm and check for a inflation.
Okay.
So you see here that that,
you know,
there are these four cycles,
things seem low in 1871,
they go up and they go down.
Then you've got another up and a down and then you've got another up and,
and down.
You've got another up and down.
Four times the same thing has happened.
Now this could be just meaningless accidents,
but it will turn out that,
um,
the demography of the country,
the baby boom cycle,
we haven't had just one baby boom we've had for them.
So this cycle of stock prices happens to court,
you know,
which is there.
Each time a generation long happens to correspond exactly to the rise,
the different age distribution of the population.
So another theory of the stock market,
which wouldn't have been entertained by these,
uh,
original,
financial theorists is that demography has something to do with the stock
market.
Not Information about profits and returns,
but the distribution of ages in the population.
So I'm not saying this theory is correct,
although I was one of the proponents of it,
but it,
it leaves,
it shows that there's room,
I think in economics and finance for economic things,
for demography to matter,
for leverage to matter,
and not just for expectations about future profits.
So let's,
let me show you another picture.
So this is a second way in which Schiller became famous.
He said,
well,
look at housing prices,
the case Shiller housing index.
So he's also famous because he had the idea of collecting housing prices.
So,
you know,
it's quite amazing.
Every town has to record,
you know,
it's it by law you have to record in the town directory and they're often on the
internet what the price is of every sale of every house.
So everybody has it and it's all publicly available on the Internet and are,
most of it is publicly available on the Internet.
And nobody thought to gather all this information together and take the average
and write down an index.
Okay.
Until Schiller did it.
So here's the Shiller index,
um,
which is all right.
So you can see that housing prices were pretty stable,
you know,
throughout the 80s.
And then in around 2000 they started taking off.
So this is when the stock market was taking off too.
So she'll says,
this is irrational exuberance.
People just went crazy.
They somehow think things can never go down and they're just gonna keep going up
and they keep buying because I think things are going to go up and it's a crazy
and things are going to,
you know,
psychology.
Eventually people are going to,
a new narrative is going to start.
Somebody is gonna say,
Oh,
they've been going up so long,
they can continue to go up.
Things have to go down.
Okay.
And things went down.
Now
I think there's something to psychology.
So there was something missing in the original finance story.
Uh,
the finance guys,
by the way,
they would say,
well,
the rise is not so surprising.
Look at the mortgage rates.
This is the interest rate you have to pay if you get a mortgage.
There's been an incredible decline in mortgage rates over the years.
So it's easier.
It's less costly to buy a housing.
If you take the present value of your expenditures on buying the house.
You know,
you just have to pay less.
So that's why the the,
you know,
uh,
you know that you pay over a long period of time.
And so the interest rate is less than.
So the,
the,
the value of the houses is worth more because you're discounting the future
benefits at a lower rate.
You'll hear all about discounting later.
So there's no mystery.
On the other hand,
they don't have anything.
Nothing happened to interest rates.
They kept getting lawyer lower.
So there's no reason why the market should have crashed.
So again,
this seems like indication for Schiller.
Now it also in ways of indication for,
for my theory,
which is non psychological.
So I,
I,
I'm distrustful a little bit of a psychology cause it can be anything.
Although I agree it's important.
So my theory is it's when you,
when you take a loan,
you have to negotiate two things.
The interest rate and how much collateral you put up,
who's going to trust you to pay back when you buy a house.
They say you can't just borrow the whole value of the house.
They say,
well make a down payment of 20% borrow 80% of the value of the house.
Okay.
And so what I say is that instead of paying all your attention to the interest
rate,
think about the collateral rate.
Why is it 20% that you have to put down?
Maybe it should be 10% or 40% well in fact that number changes all the time.
So here what I've done is the pink line from 2000 to the future.
That pink line is Schiller's housing index in Verdun.
So you notice the scale on the right is the housing prices,
but I've inverted it.
Okay.
And on the left I have the down payment percentage.
So it starts at 14 these are not,
not for,
these are non agency loans.
So I'm not going to explain the,
we'll come back to the graph later.
I don't have time to explain exactly how I got it.
Then what you see is that from 2000 onwards,
the down payment people were asked to make,
to buy their house got lower and lower and lower and lower,
and it got down to 3% you could put down 3% of the value of the House and borrow
the other 97% of the value of the house to buy it.
So amazingly,
the prices go down just with what's called the leverage.
So why is it called leverage?
Because the amount of the cash you put down payments say 10% you can lever it up
and own an asset that's worth a hundred even when you put down $10 to your
leverage,
10 to one if you put down $3 you can leverage it.
And he had $100 House you've leveraged at 30 to 133 to one so that's why it's
called leverage.
So anyway,
the point is that leverage went way up.
The margins kept going down and down and down,
and just at the peak of the housing cycle,
which is the bottom of that curve,
that's when
collateral started getting tougher.
And people started asking for more money down again.
And sure enough,
the price has turned around.
So if you look at the prices of mortgages,
again,
the inverse on the right,
and you look at the,
the margins on the left,
not for buying houses,
but for buying securities.
I don't have time to explain this whole graph,
but the blue line is the buying securities.
So 98 is a big crisis.
The margin spike up.
I don't have pricing data back till van.
That's the Blue Line.
And now from 2007 to 2009 you see the margin spiking up.
So to buy a toxic mortgage security,
you people who investors don't pay cash,
they borrow part of the money to buy it.
They used to put down only 5% to buy it.
Now they have to put down 70% to buy it on average.
Well,
what happened to prices?
Prices.
This is the inverse of prices.
In 2007 they started to collapse.
Okay,
so this going up means prices are collapsing.
So once again,
the margins,
tougher margins means lower prices.
And as the margins came down recently,
the prices have gone up recently.
So it's an alternative theory.
So,
um,
all right,
so what,
what,
uh,
all right.
So what,
what else do I want to show you?
So it doesn't mean that the standard financial theory is wrong.
After all,
I help run a hedge fund,
six of US founded it and we've been in business for 15 years.
We must believe in standard financial theory because that's how we've been
making a lot of our money and we exploit all those algorithms.
And those are the things I'm going to teach you.
So I certainly believe it and it's very important,
uh,
to teach you that again today.
But there's more,
that's the semester,
but there's more to the theory.
Um,
then just that,
so let me show you the doubt.
I want to show you one more thing in the,
in the Dow Jones or the s and P,
which I forgot to mention.
And where is this?
Oh,
I can't get it out of that.
Let's try down.
Okay.
So Dao,
hey,
where was the,
where was the peak of the Dao was right over here.
Now what was the date?
The dates falls to flash here.
Okay,
so it's October 1st,
2007.
Okay,
now let's just,
so that's when people started to realize something was wrong with the world and
things headed down.
Okay,
now why is this blood?
If you look at until then,
nothing bad seems to be happening in the world.
But suppose that you looked not at,
um,
the Dao.
Suppose you looked,
sorry.
Okay,
here's a graph.
Suppose you look.
Suppose you looked at the sub prime mortgage index.
So you see it's a hundred.
You'll understand what these things are.
So a hundred means nobody thinks there's going to be a default over here.
January,
2007,
that's 10 months before the stock market starts to go down before it hits its
peak.
The stock market is still going up here.
A month later,
this is April,
2007.
A month later,
the sub prime index starts to collapse.
You see,
it goes from a hundred to 60.
We're already in in in February or March,
2007.
So that means the people,
those experts trading mortgages already realized there was a calamity about to
happen.
This was long before anyone else perceived anything happening long before the
stock market mood,
long before the government doing anything to correct the problem.
So just as financial theory says,
if you pay attention to the prices,
you can learn a lot about the world,
the people trading those things,
their life depends on fixing the right prices.
Probably they know stuff that you don't know.
The prices are going to reflect their opinion if the price collapsed.
Part of the reason that collapsed,
maybe margins and something,
he had something to do with it.
But part of the reason that collapsed was because they knew something bad was
happening.
So for two and a half years,
we've known there's going to be a major catastrophe in the mortgage market.
You know,
a little from a hundred to 60,
since the 20 is a total calamity.
So you know that there are,
uh,
there,
there's 1.7 million people for already been thrown out of their houses.
Another three and a half million aren't paying their debts and uh,
you know,
are seriously delinquent,
probably all of them will be thrown out of their houses and another four or 5
million after them might default and have to be thrown out of their houses.
So it's a major catastrophe.
And the market told us and warned us about it two and a half years ago and
nobody's been done anything about it basically until now as we'll find out.
So it's not that I think financial theory,
the standard financial theory is wrong.
I think it's incredibly useful.
I just think it has to be supplemented by a more general and Richard Theory.
So,
um,
by the way,
just to,
maybe I should show you how my hedge fund has done just so that you don't think,
you don't think that it was a total failure.
Um,
so,
uh,
oh dear.
Where is my returns?
Here we go.
Emg Returns and sort of interesting.
So we started in 19.
So the QRP body went out of business in 1994.
There was a tremendous crash in the market.
A Lo of the levered cycle.
The purple is Ellington.
That's the hedge fun.
Uh,
you'll see that these are other investment opportunities.
The S and p 500 is the green thing,
which looked like it was doing great for a while.
Um,
emerging markets is the blue one and high yield is the green one.
And then there are a bunch of other things like treasuries and this is live war
and which is the,
what banks lend to each other at.
So this says,
if you put your money into any of those strategies,
you know,
in live where keep buying the,
lending your money each month to a bank and seeing what interests you get and
seeing how much money you accumulate or putting your money in Ellington and
looking at the purple or putting your dollars into the stock market and see what
happens.
The S and p 500,
this is what happens.
So you see there was a crash here.
You know,
you're fired,
you're fired.
So we start Ellington and pro,
you know,
Ellington does great.
And so we have all these years,
we're doing brain than 98.
There's another crash.
Look what happened overnight.
Practically,
we lost a huge amount of money.
We almost went out of business longterm capital,
which by the way was run partly by two Nobel prize winners.
Merton Miller,
not Merton Miller,
uh,
Myron shoals and,
Robert Merton,
two of the guys I mentioned with the leaders of the financial crisis,
they bankrupted their company and they went out of business.
And why did they go out of business?
Because they weren't aware of the leverage cycle in my view.
Anyway,
so the,
so the prices collapsed then look at all these returns,
shoot up again and uh,
in the world seems to be doing great.
The stock market,
everybody is doing great.
Then there's another crisis in 2007,
everything plummets.
Okay?
All together this time and then everything's going up again.
So,
you know,
it's hard to see this and to live through that.
So I remember in 98,
for example,
when there was a margin call,
our lenders called and said,
we want more money.
We don't believe that the assets are worth as much as they were,
and so the collateral is not covering alone anymore.
And we said,
you can't make a margin call.
It's not legal.
You've promised not to change the margins on it for six months.
You can't make a margin call.
And they say,
well,
blah,
blah.
We don't really know about that.
We're making a margin call.
So we called up Warren Buffet and we said,
this is terrible.
They're making a margin call.
They can't do this.
We have great bonds.
There's nothing wrong with the bonds.
There's just,
you know,
they're going to force us to sell all the bonds to pay them the money and how
can they force us to do that they shouldn't force us to do,
and we've got great bonds.
It's a great business.
It's a great company,
and they're going to run us out of bed z.
You can't let this happen.
Warren Buffet,
why don't you buy part of the company and save us and you'll get rich and it'll
be great.
He said,
say that again.
And we said,
well,
they're going to force us to sell all the bonds on Ma,
you know,
on Tuesday to,
to meet their margin call and we'll get terrible prices for the bonds will be
driven out of business even though they're great bonds,
just because they're making a margin call.
You can't let this happen to us by part of the business and save us and you'll
get rich alone part of a great company.
And he said,
hell,
it sounds like I should just show up on Tuesday and buy the bonds so that,
so we survived that.
We survived the,
I'll tell you more about what we did and we survived that.
No thanks to Warren Buffett.
And then
although he had a pretty good idea and then we,
uh,
then we,
survived the last crash.
So we survived all these crashes.
But the fact is things go up,
they crashed,
they go up,
they crash,
they go up.
Could it all be my fault?
I decided they can't be all my fault.
It's gotta be there.
Something more basic at work.
And that's why I'm going to tell you about the leverage cycle.
Now,
of course I realize that,
you know,
my pet theories may not turn out to be right,
although I think more and more people are starting to think there's something to
it.
So I'm not going to spend,
you know,
a huge portion of the course just talking about my pet theories.
I mean I recognize that,
um,
you know,
I have to teach partly what standards,
so what I'm going,
so the course is going to be divided in the following way.
I'm going to spend,
uh,
I'm going to talk about the standard nobody arbitrage financial theory and I'm
going to talk about it theoretically and mathematically and from a practical
point of view,
you know,
because how helping to run the hedge fund,
um,
you know,
lots of,
lots of the things that I'll be teaching her,
things that we actually confront and the hedge fund.
And so you'll,
you'll get the standard financial theory course taught from a hedge fund
perspective,
both theoretically and from a practical point of view.
On the other hand,
I've lived now through three mortgage crises.
And so it seems silly for me not to describe how the mortgage market works,
even when you'll find almost none of that in any standard finance textbook,
how the mortgage market works and uh,
you know,
what's going on and what happened in the crises and how we survived and how
other people didn't.
And I'll talk about the leverage cycle.
I'll also spend some time,
I think it's quite important on the mathematical logic of the invisible hand
argument.
That's the most important argument in economics.
You know,
that the free market does good for the economy and a huge number of people
believe it.
And,
and part of that argument and part of the,
the sort of hazy knowledge of that argument is what drives resistance to a lot
of government programs.
I mean the government can only screw things up is what people generally believe.
And is it a prejudice or is there some actual argument behind that?
Well,
I want to go over that argument and show you precisely how it works and how it
doesn't work and in the financial sphere.
And then I want to talk about social security.
That's one more program.
That's the biggest program in the budget.
It's as big as defense,
which then the two of those are much bigger than everything else.
A vastly bigger than every other thing and the budget.
So I want to talk about social security and you know,
should it be privatized and should it be reformed and why did it go bankrupt?
It's also an interesting mathematical problem because social security critically
involves the belief that things will go on forever.
So there's an infinity in it,
you know,
each generation,
the young are paying for the old.
Nobody would do that if they thought they were going to be the last generation
paying to the old and when they got old and nobody would help them.
So a social security rests on this world going on forever,
which makes it mathematically interesting.
And anyway,
so I got interested in it from a theorist,
radical point of view.
And then I got put in all these national academy panels and Social Security and
privatizing.
And so I,
I know quite a bit about it,
so I might as well talk about something I know about.
So that's what I'm talking about.
That.
All right.
So this is too hard for you to read.
So let's do this.
So let me just give you a few examples.
Oops.
Oh,
I hope I didn't do a terrible thing.
No.
Okay.
So let me just give you a few examples here of the kinds of,
just so you think there's,
you realize there's something to the standard theory,
there's a lot to it.
So I'll give you 10 examples very quickly of the standard theory.
So these are things that I'm guessing you'll have at least some of them trouble
figuring out how to answer now,
but by the end of the course is they should be totally obvious to you.
So,
um,
suppose you win the lottery,
$40 million or $100 million.
The lottery now,
they always give you the choice.
Do you want to take 5 million a year,
over 20 years or just get $40 million right now?
Which would you do?
And how do you think about what to do?
Okay,
that one.
so now you get tenure at Yale at the age of 50.
Say you're making $150,000 a year and you think you know professors and she's
going to go up with the rate of inflation and that's about it for the next 20
years to your retire and then so that's 20 years of that,
and then you're going to live another 20 years when you're going to be making
nothing.
Okay?
So how much of the 150,000 this,
and let's say inflation is 3% and what you'd like to do is consume inflation,
corrected the same amount every year after you retire and before you retire.
So how much of the 150,000 should you spend this year and how much should you
save?
Okay,
that's another,
you learn very quickly how to do a problem like that.
Okay?
Now,
President Levin wrote a few months ago,
the end of last year,
if you remember,
he said that,
well,
the crisis was bad.
You know,
Yale was going to,
whether it,
but Yale did lost 25% probably of its endowment.
That's $5 billion almost of the $23 billion endowment.
So how much should he choose to cut his decision?
How much should Yale reduce spending every year spending?
The total spending a year is a little over 2 billion.
So the endowment goes down by 5 billion.
What cuts did you take to the budget?
Should faculty salaries be cut,
be frozen?
Should,
uh,
you know,
the TA's,
should you have three tas instead of four tas?
Should you,
what should you do?
How big a cut should you take?
Now,
the same question faced Yale in 1996 or so,
I forgotten exactly the year,
10 or 12 years ago,
the previous President Benno Schmidt,
he suddenly noticed that there was deferred maintenance as he called it,
$1 billion to fix the Yale buildings.
That's why incidentally,
every year another college gets fixed.
They decided there was deferred maintenance of $1 billion.
It had $100 million every year for 10 years had to be spent.
Uh,
the whole endowment then was 3 billion,
and now we had a $1 billion deferred maintenance problem.
The budget was about 1 billion.
Then.
So how much should you cut the Yale budget?
At that time.
So bound Schmidt's said,
I'm firing 15% of the faculty.
You announced he was firing 15% of the faculty that was in the front pages of
the New York Times yell to fire faculty.
Well,
did,
did he make the right decision?
Rick 11 took over his presidents three months later.
So probably not,
but
what mistake did he make in his calculations?
What should he have done?
What was the right response?
Okay,
so we're going to talk about,
okay,
so that's something you should be able to,
so it's not that hard a problem.
Um,
now let's take a,
let's take a slightly more complicated one.
You're a bookie,
uh,
and you're,
the world series is coming up.
The Yankees are playing the Dodgers,
let's say,
and you know that the teams are evenly matched and you've got a bunch of friends
who,
you know,
every game we'll be willing to bet and even odds on either side because they're,
they think it's the,
that's a toss up.
One of your customers comes to you and says,
he's a Yankee Fan.
He's sure the Yankees are gonna win.
He's willing to put up $300,000 to bet on the Yankees,
which he loses it.
So if the Yankees,
when he gets 200,000 but at the Yankees lose,
he loses 300,000.
So three to two odds,
he's willing to bet on the Yankees winning what you say,
this guy is sort of a soccer here.
I can take a big advantage of them.
On the other hand,
the guys,
it's a lot of money.
200,000 I might lose,
you know,
if I,
uh,
if I have to pay off in the Yankees win.
So even though I think that,
uh,
you know,
the odds are in my,
I,
my expected profit as positive because he's putting up 300,000 to make only 200
when they're even odds.
In fact,
the fact is it's such a big number.
I don't,
you know,
I'm a little worried about that.
So what do you do?
So what can you do?
You've got these friends who were willing to bet it even odds each game by game.
So how much money,
presumably the first night you're going to bet with one of your friends or you
take the guy's bad,
the customer,
you,
you take us 300,000 you promised to deliver in 500 back if the Yankees win and
to keep it,
if the Yankees lose,
what should you do with your friends?
Should you bet on the Yankees with your friends?
Should you bout on the Dodgers with your friends and how much should you bet at
even odds the first night?
Okay,
so that doesn't,
so the answer is,
well,
I don't want to give all the answers now,
but so there is a way of skillfully bedding with your friends and not betting
200 or 300,000 the first night with your friends and even odds,
you bet some different number than that,
which you'll figure out how much to bet so that if you keep betting through the
course of the world series,
you can never lose a penny.
Okay?
But how do you know how much that is?
Well,
that's the kind of clever thing that you're going to,
you know,
these finance guys developed and you're going to know how to do.
So let's do another example like that one thing at a time,
a little bit,
but one an example.
Suppose as a deck of cards,
26 red in 26 black cards,
somebody offers to play a game with you.
They say every time if you want to pick a card and it's black,
I'll give you a dollar.
If it's red,
you give me a dollar.
So if I'm picking,
I get a dot.
I'm in the black,
I get a dollar,
it's in the red,
I lose a dollar.
I have to throw away the card after I pick it.
And the guy says,
by the way,
you can quit whenever you want.
All right,
so should you pick the first card?
Looks like an even chance of winning or losing.
But say you pick the first card,
it's black,
you win a dollar.
Now the guy says,
do you want to do it again?
The deck is 26 you picked a black one.
So there's 26 red left and 25 black.
So it's now the deck is stacked against you.
Should you pick another card?
Well,
it doesn't sound like you should pick another card,
but you shouldn't pick another card.
And I can even tell you how many cards to pick,
even if you keep getting blacks who should keep picking and picking.
So how could that be?
It sounds kind of shocking.
Well,
it's going to turn out to be very simple for you to solve,
uh,
halfway through the course.
So let suppo let's,
uh,
let's a more basic question.
Let's suppose that you,
you know,
they're 30 year mortgages now you can get for five and three quarter percent
interest.
They're 15 year mortgages.
You can get for less,
like 5.3% interest.
I'm one's lower than the other.
Should you take the 15 year mortgage with a 30 year mortgage?
How do you even think about that?
Why do they offer one at a lower price than the other?
Um,
okay.
And one more example.
Suppose you're a bank and you hold a bunch of mortgages.
That means the people in the houses of,
you've lent them the money,
they're promising to pay you back and you value all of those mortgages at $100
million,
the interest rates go down,
the government lowers the interest rates,
half of them take advantage to refinance that pay you back what they owe and
they refinance into a new mortgage.
So now you've only got half the people left.
Let's say all the people had the same size mortgages and everything,
half the people are left.
Is that shrunken pool?
Half as big as the original pool?
Is that worth 50 million,
half of what it was before or more than 50 or less than 50 million?
How would you decide that?
Again,
this is a question which might be a little puzzling now,
but actually you should be able to get the sign of that today even.
And um,
and we'll start to analyze it.
So that's what mortgage traders have to do.
They see interest weight,
it's went down.
A bunch of people acted,
the people were left in the pool are different from the people who started in
the pool.
Now we've got to reevaluate everything and we think at all so well how should we
do that?
Okay.
Um,
let's say you run a hedge fund and some investor comes to you and says,
ah,
things are terrible.
Look at all the money you lost from me last year.
Um,
you know,
I know you're doing great this year and you've made it all back that you lost
last year.
But you know,
I don't want to run that risk.
So I want to give you a month,
my money,
$1 billion.
I want to get the superior returns you seem to earn,
but you have to guarantee that you don't lose me a penny.
I don't want to run any risk.
I want a principal guarantee.
It's called that when I give you $100,
I'll never have,
you know,
you'll always return my hundred dollars and hopefully much more,
but never less than a hundred dollars.
So is there any way to do that?
Or you know,
you know that you're,
you've got a great strategy,
but of course it's risky.
You could lose money.
You've lost money a bunch of times before.
So how can you guarantee the guy that he'll get all his money back and still
have room to run your strategy?
Well,
it sounds like you can't do it,
but of course a lot of people want to invest that way,
so there must be a way to do it.
So you'll figure out,
learn how to do that.
So,
uh,
three more short ones.
A scientist discovers a potential cure for aids.
If it works,
he's gonna make a fortune.
He started a company,
it's like Yale scientist,
he's medical school,
started the startup company,
Yale,
of course it's going to take all his profits.
But anyway,
he'd start up company and if this thing really works,
he's going to make a fortune.
If it doesn't work,
it's going to be totally zero.
You calculate and let's say you believe your calculation,
that the expected profits that he'll make if it works,
you know,
the probability of it working times the profits that expected profit is equal to
the profits of all of General Electric.
Should his company would be worth more than General Electric.
The same as general electric or less than General Electric.
Since it's got the same expected profits.
Well,
I can tell you the answer to this one because I think most of you would think
first.
You think,
well maybe the same.
Then you'd say,
well this aids thing,
it's so risky.
It's either going to be way up here or nothing.
And that's so risky and general electric is so solid.
Probably the general electric is worth more.
But the answer is the AIDS company's worth more.
So how could that be?
So,
uh,
another kind of another question.
Suppose you believed in the sufficient market stuff and you rank all the stocks
at the end of this year from top to bottom of which stock had the highest return
over the year.
It was 2010,
let's say 2010.
This year is a weird year.
So let's say you do it in 2010 all the stocks,
the highest return to the lowest return.
Now suppose you did the same thing in 2011 with the same stocks would expect to
get the same order or the reverse order.
We're random order now.
Again,
if you believe in efficient markets and the markets really functioning,
the prices are fair and all,
I'll bet most of you will say
he won't know,
but you might say,
should be random the next time because you know,
firms only did better or worse by luck,
but that's not right either.
So you're gonna know how to answer that question by the end of the class.
Um,
okay,
one last one.
The Yale endowment over the last 15 years has gotten something like a 15%
annualized return.
I hedge fund that I won't name has gotten 11% over the last 15 years,
counting all its losses and stuff like that.
So is it obvious that the Yale endowment has done better than the hedge fund?
Would you say that the Yale manager is better than the hedge fund manager?
It's returned was 15% the hedge fund only got 11%.
So I'm asking the question.
Um,
and I would say that David Swinson would think about it the same way I think
about it.
So,
um,
suppose I even told you that the Yale Hedge Fund had lower volatility than the
at the Yale hedge from the yell and Darwin had lower volatility than the hedge
fund.
Um,
which it surely does.
Would that,
uh,
convince you now that the Yale endowment had been managed better than the hedge
fund?
Well,
we're going to answer this question again and you're going to see that the
answer is a little surprising.
So of,
of who'd be so surprising,
I wouldn't have brought it up at one anyway.
So now the,
but anyway,
that's the kind of thing that in finance you're taught to think about.
So the crisis of 2007,
which you're going to spend a long time talking about.
I just want to get back to that subject.
Okay.
So,
um,
so the,
those lists of questions where the kinds of things that I used to teach for
years before I was confident about my theory of crises.
And this is the kind of questions you have to face all the time at hedge funds
and decisions you have to make and things you have to tell investors.
And so that's,
that's the basic part of the course.
But I want to say more so I want to talk about the crisis of 2007 2009 it
started as a mortgage crisis.
Okay.
Now how could it be that everything goes wrong and mortgages?
I mean,
there are 4,000 years old.
The Babylonians invented mortgages.
You know,
what is a mortgage?
You lend somebody money,
they put up collateral,
they don't pay.
You take the house or you take the guy's life,
he's a slave or something.
But it's the same thing.
You put your borrow money and the guy promises you can confiscate something if
he doesn't pay 4,000 years and we screwed it up.
How could that,
how could that be so wa and why should a screw up in the mortgage market have
such a big effect on the rest of the economy?
You know,
were subprime mortgage is a terrible idea or was there some logic to it?
Um,
and how did we get out of the crisis?
How is it that everybody was,
this is the worst crisis since the depression may be another depression and
things seemed to have turned around.
What is it that we did to get things to turn around?
I don't think we're out of it yet,
but things are a lot better than they were a year ago.
So what is it that the government did to turn things around?
It didn't do nearly enough,
I think,
but it did something.
What exactly,
what did it do now?
Schiller,
you know,
we'll talk about the whole thing was irrational exuberance,
I'm going to say is all the leverage cycle.
Um,
but anyway,
so that's the mortgage crisis now are free markets.
Good.
Okay.
I want to talk about the argument that the most,
the argument was first made by Adam Smith about the invisible hand.
The modern mathematical argument is Ken Arrow's my thesis advisor.
And um,
you know,
of course everybody knows that monopoly and pollution and things like that
interfere with the free market and they have to be regulated.
But the financial markets,
there's no monopoly.
And as long as there's no monopoly and there's no pollution,
shouldn't the free market function there.
So I want to go over that argument and show you what was missing in and as I
said before,
and then lastly we're going to talk about social security and a,
you know,
how could that system be going bankrupt?
I mean,
it just seems shocking.
You know,
there's a two Chilean dollar trust fund.
It's going to run out in 10 or in,
you know,
in 2024 or something.
And after that the system will be broke.
And uh,
so how did it happen?
Why is it broke?
What can we do to fix it?
You know?
So George Bush said,
well,
it's terrible.
Even if we manage to sort of get the trust fund rehabilitated,
young people like you are going to get a 2% rate of return if you put your money
in the stock.
Even allowing for the last crash over the long haul,
the returns have been 6%.
So it's terrible.
Social Security,
something's wrong with the system.
We should prioritize it and let everybody,
young people,
like you put your money in stocks instead.
Well Gore and the debate in 2000 said,
you can't do that because then the old people are expecting their money can't
get paid.
And both of them agreed that,
you know,
it was all the baby boomers fault.
You know,
people like me,
we're getting old,
we're going to retire.
That's why the system is going to get broken.
So that's the conventional wisdom.
All three of those things are wrong.
Um,
so we're going to find out why.
Okay,
so that's the bait.
So in summary,
you know,
why study finance,
it's to understand the financial system,
which is really part of the economic system is to make informed choices.
You know,
is privatizing social security a good or bad thing?
Uh,
you know,
as regulation of financial markets,
a good thing,
uh,
you know,
the language that you'll learn is the language that's,
that's spoken on Wall Street and was created by professors and yet practitioners
use it.
It's increased.
I think it's,
for me,
it's incredibly fun.
And all these little puzzles,
as JP Morgan said,
money is just a way of keeping score.
You know,
you have to figure out what something's worth in the end.
And if you get it right,
you've,
you've solved the puzzle,
right?
And,
uh,
you know,
it'll help you make good financial decisions and a potential career.
That's the standard reason to take a financed other prerequisites of the course.
So I want to make this clear,
you don't really need econ one 15,
it will be helpful because this logic of the free market being good or bad,
you know,
that was already started an econ one 15,
that's what they call it now don't,
right?
Still called one 15.
Right?
So,
um,
I used to teach it,
but I haven't done it for years.
So anyway,
um,
what you really need is mathematical self confidence.
It's not going to be high math.
It's going to be simple math,
but it's relentless over and over again.
And I can tell you that every year there's the 5% of the s you know,
of you,
let's say five or 10 out of the hundred 20 are going to just get bored doing
problem after problem.
And you're probably not that,
you know,
those 10 maybe haven't that much experience doing it.
Don't feel very confident doing it.
Stop coming to the class and then really have no idea what's going on.
So if,
you know,
my sister is probably much smarter than I am,
but she doesn't like math,
I wouldn't,
you know,
she wouldn't take this course.
So if you're not confident doing little mathematical problems,
just don't take the course,
you'll save yourself a lot of trouble.
I don't know how to say this any better.
I want to warn you not to do it.
It's easy math,
but it never stops.
Every week there's going to be a problem set the exam,
their problem sets,
the exam is doing problems just like the problem sets.
But if you don't like that,
you know,
to me,
uh,
finance is a quantitative subject.
What's so beautiful about it.
And one aspect I really like is that you have these complicated different things
you have to weigh.
But at the end you have to come up with one number.
What is the price you're willing to pay for something?
It's very concrete and I'm going to take advantage of the concreteness by
turning every question into,
to a number.
I hate it when you get on the one hand and on the other hand and you know,
you know it's the number.
And so the,
so if you don't like numbers,
it's not a good course to take.
So what are the kinds of things you have to know?
You have to understand the distributor law of Arithmetic,
you know,
which,
uh,
I,
I have little kids and I see that's not so easy to understand anyway.
And then you have to understand the idea of a function,
which is a contingent plan.
Simultaneous equations as we do for equilibrium in arbitrage taking a
derivative.
That's marginal utility,
the idea of diminishing marginal utility,
a concave function that's looks like that.
That's risk aversion.
You know,
bankers invented the logarithm compound interest.
You have to know what taking a log rhythm and the exponential means,
and you have to understand how to take probability weighted averages and things.
And,
and we're gonna use Xcel for a lot of the problems which we'll teach you,
which you can learn in that by the end of the day,
you'll be better at it than I am.
Uh,
so my office hours or four to six,
my secretary is rent assistant,
has rent day,
there's an accent missing.
And she always tells me Wilson,
she just started three days ago,
but I'm sure she'll be great.
They're going to be two lectures a week and a ta section.
So every Tuesday there'll be a problem set starting this Tuesday,
do the next Tuesday there'll be two midterms.
You know,
there's a lot of stuff to learn and,
and so I found everybody I think agrees who's taken the course.
If you take the midterm,
it will focus your mind and make it a lot easier.
So I give two of them's,
you only have half the course to study.
It makes the final much easier to study for.
I recognize that some of you will have problems on one of like,
especially the first midterm.
And if you do vastly worse than one exam than the rest,
I'll tend to ignore that.
Um,
but most people don't by the way,
do vastly worse on one exam and the rest.
Um,
so then finals 40,
the problem sets 20 and the two midterms or 20 Tuesday to Tuesday.
And so all the ta sessions or Thursday to Monday,
so they're going to start next Thursday.
So you see the two classes,
you know the classes are Tuesday,
Thursday,
then the next Tuesday there's a long time in between here.
So all the ta sessions we'll meet there.
So are there at the same moment in the class,
I don't have a t.
There are all these textbooks all by the Nobel prize winners all by those
financial grades.
You can buy any one of them.
Um,
but I have my own lecture notes.
Uh,
cause as I say,
I take us teach a slightly unconventional course and there's a huge list of
books on the crisis and some of them are incredibly interesting and fun.
And so they're all on the reading list.
You can take a look at.
I mean there's never been a more fun time to read this stuff now.
Um,
okay.
So of course improvements anyway,
so I'm gonna now.
Okay,
so that's it.
Are there any questions about how the course runs or how I will run it or
whether you think you should take the course or whether your preparation.
So if you haven't taken econ 15 it's okay.
One 15 but you've got to be confident that you can solve problems otherwise
don't do it.
Any questions?
Yes,
it will be a second next.
Yeah.
So next Tuesday it's going to be due the Tuesday after.
So I know it's early,
but you know,
you probably already know whether you're going to take the course or not.
Yes,
next year.
Well I teach at next year.
Um,
actually I probably won't because I'm going to go on leave,
but I might,
but probably not.
But you,
you know,
someone else will teach it.
Yup.
Yes.
I don't really suggest,
you know,
but they're all good.
So they're all,
you know,
they're all famous people have written,
the books are too,
you know,
they're trying to sell copies so they're pitched at a quite low level and
they're,
but they're very good.
So I would,
you know,
any one of them is good.
Miller's book,
um,
Merton's book is good.
So is Steve Ross is a friend of mine.
He used to teach at Yale,
so his book is good.
So any one of those is very good,
but they're not quite at the same mathematical level because they're trying to
sell,
you know,
thousands of bucks and they stick quit pretty,
pretty closely to this financial view of the world that everything's efficient.
Yes.
Rolling.
Oh,
that's a good question.
I don't think so.
No.
They're shaking their head so it won't be in time for you,
but it will be if you want to look back in your old age.
I was there.
I saw the leverage cycle.
Sorry.
Yes.
Oh,
the lecture notes are all posted a already before the class.
So the first 12 of them are there and I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm changing.
I'm each year,
so there'll be some changes.
So last year his first 12 were there and they might change a little bit,
but you can already get an idea of what they're about.
This first lecture is not on,
um,
but the rest of them aren't.
Any other questions?
Yes.
When did we send out?
Oh,
you should be signing up now.
I think it's,
I don't know how to do this online or something.
Right.
You sign up online.
Yeah.
So you should pick your sections.
We might add another section if all of you stay,
but you know,
probably you won't.
So,
but if we do,
we'll add another ta section.
Okay.
Yes.
What's degree distribution?
Great Distribution.
I don't know.
The Standard Yale junior level course grade distribution,
which is,
you know,
when I was at Yale,
things where my things weren't much tougher.
But um,
so it's the standard distribution.
I don't remember it off hand,
but I'll tell you all about the distribution at the midterm.
So there'll be a midterm before you have a chance to,
you have a chance to drop the course after the midterm and,
and then there'll be another midterm right at the end of the day.
Of course,
yes.
Okay.
I was trying to say that.
I'm glad you asked me again.
So I went over the things you have to know,
you have to be able to take,
if you have three x minus four x squared,
you have to be able to take the derivative of that just three minus eight x.
If you've got the log natural of x,
you have to take the derivative.
It's one over x.
If you've got three x plus five equals 10 and two x minus seven equals 12 you
have to be able to solve that simultaneous equation.
So that's the kind of thing you have to do and you have to be able to do it
quickly and with total confidence that you're doing it right.
And you know from up,
for many of you,
that's no problem.
But for some of you who are maybe even smarter than everybody else,
that's a problem.
And so you'll have to judge yourself whether you can do that comfortably.
So you don't have to worry about the mechanics of doing that.
You can think conceptually about what the question's asking.
Okay?
All right.
I want to do one x that we have.
When does this end?
10 of or quarter of or
10 of.
Okay.
So we have 15,
13 minutes.
So I want to end with one experiment.
So,
um,
be gay.
Can you help me with this?
So this is something we're not going to have time to figure out the answer to,
but
so,
okay,
so what I have,
so I need 16 volunteers.
How about the first two roles?
Why don't you just volunteer?
You'll survive and you know,
I know it's a drag,
but you'll do it.
Okay.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to just,
I'm going to run an auction.
So please stand up and eight of you go to this site,
eight,
come over here and that's okay.
You'll be okay.
I know everyone's reluctant to do this,
so I only need 16 be gay.
Help me count them.
Two,
four,
six,
eight.
Okay.
You,
you guys have to come the other way.
The TA's aren't going to participate.
You don't need to,
yeah,
you're not in this,
right?
Yeah.
No.
Two,
four,
six,
eight.
So we only need eight would you?
My weight.
One of you.
You both sat down.
So would you like to participate?
Come on.
We can use another woman here.
Okay.
Two,
four,
six,
eight.
There are eight of them.
Okay.
So can you mix these up?
They're going to be eight sellers and eight you say seller,
right?
Buyer.
So shuffle them up and handle on teach.
Okay,
so we've got eight and these are the football they're selling.
So we've got eight sellers and eight buyers.
And I don't know whether you've ever seen this experiment before.
I didn't one but shuffle them right there in,
they're all sellers,
but you've got to shuffle them on the other side is a number.
Okay?
So we've got eight sellers here and eight buyers.
So each seller knows,
um,
what his football ticket is worth or hurt.
So please take one.
Thank you,
mark giving you so many others.
Oh,
you have a seller one.
That's bad.
Yeah,
I'm blind.
Thank you.
By earth.
There's just say buyer and buyer.
Okay.
You shouldn't be one short.
Here's an extra.
Did you?
Okay.
So there are eight sellers and eight buyers.
They've got the football tickets.
Each of them knows what the football ticket is worth to her.
Okay.
We'll be three women here,
only two.
So these are the hers,
they,
each one of them now she knows exactly what it's worth to her.
So say it's 15 football tickets worth 15 now she can sell it for more than 15
she's going to do it.
She's going to make a profit.
If she sells it for less than 15 she's not a very good trader.
Okay.
She's not going to do that.
She's going to say,
if I can get more than the football ticket is worth,
I'm going to sell it.
If I can get worse,
if I can't get more than it's worth,
I won't sell it.
Okay.
So everybody knows what the football ticket is worth to herself.
All these guys,
they know what the ticket is worth to them.
So say someone thinks it's worth 30 that guy's going to say,
if I can get it for less than 30 like for 15 I'm going to get it.
If I can get,
you know,
they'll give me a profit of 15 if I can only get it for 40 I'm sure not going to
do that because I'm paying more than I think it's worth.
Okay,
so you all got that.
You have a reservation value yourself.
You don't want to pay more than it's worth because then you're losing money and
they want to sell it for more than they think it's worth cause then they're
making money.
Okay.
So nobody knows anybody else's valuation that the information is distributed
completely randomly across the class.
Now this is a famous experiment.
I'm not the first one to run it off.
I've done it for 10 years.
I do it my graduate class in my undergraduate class,
the undergraduates,
and by the way,
I always do better than the graduate students.
But anyway,
so the,
this knowledge is distributed in the whole environment and we're going to see
what happens when I start a chaotic interaction between all of these 16 people.
What's going to happen?
And you would think it'd be total chaos and nothing sensible is going to happen.
And I,
if that does happen,
it'll be very embarrassing for me.
But what the efficient markets guys would say is something amazing is going to
happen.
The market is going to discover what everybody thinks it's worth and,
and figure out exactly the best and right thing to do.
And that's what's going to happen.
Now it's hard to believe that with this little preparation that you've had zero,
zero training,
zero experience,
and they're only going to have two minutes to do this.
So we see the classes got eight minutes to go.
You're not gonna,
you're gonna miss the grand finale anyway,
so you're only gonna go.
So with only,
uh,
only two minutes of trading,
they're going to get to a result,
which if I had to do it myself and read all the numbers and sort the mountain
sort throw them would take me much more than two minutes.
And all of this is going to happen in two minutes.
It's hard to believe it probably won't happen this time.
So here are the rules.
I'm going to put you all together and start inching your way towards each other.
Okay?
And try not,
okay.
Now when I say go,
which won't be for two minutes,
you're going to start yelling out an offer.
So if you think it's worth 15 and you're a seller,
you're not going to sell it for 15 you're going to say,
give me 20 or giving me 30 or giving me,
you know,
25 you're going to try and get as much as you can.
You have to yell it out.
Someone else,
you know,
the buyers are going to making their offers.
When two of you see that there's a deal,
you have to shake hands,
exchange the football and leave and tell your numbers to be gay.
Where's be gay.
Okay.
Be Gay.
You're gonna stand outside the group
outside the box that way.
Okay.
So once you make a deal,
you just leave and tell what's happened to be gay.
Okay?
Who's now standing back here?
Back there.
Okay.
So you,
uh,
so it has to be public outcry.
It's very important that you're yelling these things publicly and every,
all the other people can hear you.
And you've only got two minutes now.
Two minutes sounds like two minutes.
Sounds like an incredibly short period of time,
which it is,
but it's much longer than you think.
You wait quiet here,
you shouldn't trade.
I'm giving you valuable advice.
You shouldn't.
You should not trade in the first 10 or 15 seconds cause you have to hear what
everybody else is offering.
If you trade right away,
you're probably doing something really stupid.
Two minutes.
No,
it sounds short.
It's actually a very long period of time.
So be patient.
Try to get the best possible price and we'll see what happens.
Any questions about what you're doing?
And now in the heat of the moment,
you might,
you know,
be so frustrated that you can't sell when you think it's worth 15 that you sell
it for 10 I'm going to expose you in front of all these people who do that.
So keep track of what you think is worth.
All right?
Any questions?
Anybody about what a is going on?
Okay,
so you have two minutes.
Is there a second hand there?
I can't see it.
No,
it's,
it's on the,
where is it?
It's on the three.
Okay.
I think I see something.
Okay,
so when it gets to the four,
we're going to start.
So start,
go.
Oh no,
he made a deal.
Tell gay
how much time is left?
Like one minute left.
Okay.
Plenty of time.
One minute.
Okay.
Any other deal made
right down the price and the two.
Uh,
what price they agreed.
How much time?
25 seconds.
Stay.
Cool.
How much time?
I can't see it.
15 stay cool.
Don't make any mistakes.
Ten five,
four,
three,
two,
one stop.
Okay.
Did you get all the numbers?
How much was it?
Give me back the tickets.
The tickets in the mind is to make it look bad on camera.
You're gonna look great on camera.
You are
okay.
Give me all the tickets.
Back to collusion word.
It's a good idea.
Okay.
Be Gay.
You're getting done there.
Okay.
Well with tickets,
I need them all back.
And all this stuff come out of your big folders here.
You know this,
these tickets have lasted 10 years till you guys took over.
Oh,
okay.
There are their own crumpled up and okay.
All the tickets here.
I meet them all back.
Okay,
you can sit down now.
Everybody's reported in.
Okay,
now let's see what happened.
Okay?
Yep.
Okay.
Five,
five traded,
five.
Five bought and sold.
Okay.
Okay,
so Stan.
so here's what happened here.
Where the numbers,
okay,
so we have five minutes just to look at this.
So all the buyer prices are in blue,
44 40 36 you should recognize these you buyers and the red ones where the
sellers.
So you notice that every seller for everybody,
there's a seller who's underneath.
Okay?
So it could have happened that 38th sold to 44 and 34 sold to 40 at 37 and 28
sold to 36 and 32 all that could've,
you could've had eight trades.
So what did happen?
Nothing like that happened.
You had five trades,
five pairs of people traded and they're loose.
Three poor schlumps pairs of people at the end looking,
despondent,
hopeless,
unable to trade,
worry that they were on camera.
So
now let's see who are the people who traded?
So be gay.
Name the buyers who bought,
you don't need to buy the prices.
No.
Okay.
It was all quick.
So I don't have everybody's name.
They were all the,
the of you didn't get the,
you got them.
Okay,
great.
so here's what happened.
Um,
Mr. Seller 10 sold the 36 at a price of 20.
Mr. Seller,
nine sold to buy or 29 there is no nine
oh six
nine sold to 20 at a price of six.
That's okay.
So seller six sold at a price to 20 at a price of 20
no,
no by or 20 paid 20 so sellers six did.
Well we won't ask who?
Buyer 20th buyer 20 okay.
It's going to screw everything up.
So buyer a 14 through,
I can't read this either.
44 buyer 14 sold to buyer 44 for 20 and buyer 20 sold to buyer 40 for 22 and and
buyer 24 sold to seller 24 sold to buyer 34 25 okay,
so five people traded now which five were they?
Sellers were ten six 14 and 24 one two three four five the bottom five,
the five buyers,
we're 30 we're 36 2044 40 and 30 so basically the 444036302016 bike,
20 buttons dead.
So if you look at it,
so it's not quite the way theory would have predicted,
but almost if you look at it,
um,
if you look at it,
if you just shuffle the,
the,
the order and he put the sellers instead of from top to bottom,
you just put them from bottom to top.
You get what looks like a demand curve and a supply curve.
And so what happened,
all these five people ended up selling one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Those were exactly the sellers.
The price they sold for was all between 20 and 25 and the five buyers were
444036302016 manage to buy but 20 baht.
So basically the fee.
So what is what,
so what is the free,
what is the theory of the free market?
The theory of the free market says this chaotic situation where they had less
than two minutes to decide what to do,
could be analyzed as if you put a demand curve together with a supply curve.
And there was one price that they miraculously new here it was,
should have been 25.
It turned out to be 20 or 22 that all the trades took place that at that one
price you get all the trades happening.
The people who have the highest valuation buyers,
they're the ones who get the tickets.
The people with the lowest valuation sellers sell it.
So the people who end up with the tickets are these red guys at the top.
And the blue guys at the top,
all the tickets go from the least good God will delete,
not good least.
Uh,
people value the stuff at least to the people who value it more.
So the market has done an extraordinary thing and two minutes.
So there was one mistake,
Mister or miss 20,
whose identity we are protecting,
although I'm searching the faces,
Mister or miss 20 got a very bad deal.
She or he,
let's say he bought a 21,
the value was 20.
That was a horrible deal.
He so he,
he shouldn't have,
you know,
he didn't get any extra out of it.
So he should probably have only bought if the price were lower and then 26 would
have bought instead of 20.
So 20 sort of squeezed his way into the market.
So 26 and 20 between them,
somehow there was a slight inefficiency,
but basically with no training,
no background,
no practice.
These 16 undergraduates managed to reproduce.
They gathered all the information,
the whole economy,
and they discovered who are the fifth who are the eight and the,
sorry,
when were the 16 the eight people who valued the tickets to the most and they
ended up with all the tickets,
you know,
for me to do it and sort it out.
We're take him longer.
The market solves a complicated problem and gets information incredibly quickly
and puts things into the hands of the people who value it the most.
And the marginal buyer thought it was worth about 25 or 20 and that's what the
price turned out to be.
So anyway,
we're going to come back to this parable,
the beginning of the next class.